الشاب يعني انت تقول مثلا انه لماذا تنتظر
مرحله عمريه معينه حتى تنعم بالمرحله
الملكيه خذ بها من الان فقليل من دروس
الحياه ما تاخذه بالمجن كانك تتحدث عن
الشباب ربما صحيح
صحيح
لكن الشاب الشاب يجب ان يعيش حاله كفاح
حاله صراع حاله تنافس حاله تجاوز للصعوبات
والتحديات والعقبات وغير من من الامور
وهذا بالتالي يتنافر ربما او يتناقض مع
مصطلح المرحله الملكيه المرحله الملكيه يا
صديقي لا تدعو الى القعود ولا تدعو الى
الى الدعاء ولا تدعوا الى الى التجمل هي
تدعو الى انك توحدها
وتكثف جهودك وتوزعها تجاهك هي هي في
جملتها لو لاحت هي تدعوا الى الى خزان
طاقتك صحه العباره لا يثقبض تحافظ عليه
تحافظ هو الاكسل انا لا ليست الدعوه الى
القعود والعزال عن الحياه الحياه جمالها
في العطاء الحياه جمالها في ان يكون من
مشروع في الحياه وان تتقدم جزء كبير من
سعادتك ويعني وان اقول والله يا اخي
وتقليدك
الذي خلق الذين يخلدون رئيس القاعدون
والذكر للانسان عمر ثاني الذكر الطيب يكون
بالعطاء وبالعمل لكن انا اقول عن طريق بس
فقط والله ان تفعل شيء من الفلتره فقط انت
تتجنب بعض المر وانت تتعامل مع بعض الامور
بطريقتين معينه